before i start i'd like to introduce
myself my name is andrea bodnar i have
just graduated with my phd from mit i
was working on natural language
processing over there i'm currently the
chief data scientist at movable inc
which is a startup just next door
and um i'd like to start with a little
bit of a grander vision and
i would like to
i'd like to bring you guys back to 2010
when the haitian earthquake happened
and what happened over there is was a
catastrophe the local government was not
equipped to handle the situation and
most of the help came from international
team
those rescue teams did not the local
language and it was very hard for them
to communicate with the locals to
understand where they had to provide
help where the the rest of the uh family
members were located and what were their
injuries so you can see why it's so
important for us to language
understanding and actually um
be able to handle the numerous languages
that exist uh
today uh on this world
and the first question that might come
to your mind is how many languages
there are around 7 000 languages that
we speak today to a various degree and
those languages can be categorized
based on how many people speak them and
the largest category of languages
contains around 4 000 languages we call
those small languages because they have
a small vocabulary and also
a rather limited range of expressivity
those small languages are spoken by only
point percent of the world's population
the very next category contains 3 000
languages and those are spoken by twenty
percent of the world's population those
three thousand languages are so-called
uh medium-sized languages
and the last category spoken by eighty
percent of the world's population
contains only eighty
and you might say okay you have a
problem to solve why don't you just
focus on those 83 languages right if you
if you solve that problem you make 80
percent of the world's population happy
but we've been trying and for decades
we've put research into trying to
understand
those languages and we could do is
tackle around half of those languages
and
roughly speaking
we can computationally model around 40
languages
and the problem we have is that language
is the key to communication but we are
yet to successfully simulate it
and the current approaches we have taken
so far resemble more or less a language
puzzle where you'd start with small
pieces and you try to build on top of
them in order to gain an understanding
of what language actually means and what
it tries to convey
um in trying to understand this puzzle
we start with the simple things with
words and sentences and once we've
identified the words and the sentences
we move on
and we know that some languages have
millions of words and we want to cut
into
something that we call word categories
those are actually parts of speech and
some of those parts of speech are things
like nouns verbs adverbs adjectives
so you have those two things together
and the next thing you try to do uh with
the combination computational system is
to understand the relations that exist
between the words those are called
syntactic relations and they're
concerned with things like is this uh
noun actually dependent on the verb or
is this now dependent on another verb
and you try to build uh structural
deficiencies that
handle the grammatical
arrangement of a sentence
and what those three pieces are in you
you move further along and you focus on
semantics and semantics is really
important because it's actually going to
help you understand the meaning of the
language
the meaning of the language is a very
complex thing to handle because
depending on the context i'm saying
something i might mean a totally
different thing and this is what
pragmatics tries to figure out so for
example if i am to say uh i hate you
right does it actually mean i hate you
uh if i'm saying it with a smile on my
face probably not so pragmatic stress to
understand given the context uh what is
it that the
speaker actually tries to convey
and once those puzzle pieces are put
together we can say that we've
understood the specific language and we
can build computational models to
simulate it
but the big picture doesn't look that
great for english we might have this
puzzle and we know how to simulate this
language by looking at other languages
like german or korean
the puzzle looks incomplete or barely
touched and languages like english we
called resource rich because we have
linguistic resources for them
while languages like korean are resource
poor now what i mean by resources those
are language models linguistic knowledge
and annotations
for those of you who do not have a
linguistic background annotations are
our way to evaluate how well a
computational model performs and
annotations are actually
built by a set of people we uh
we assign this task of annotating
documents for a specific linguistic
phenomenon and then we
build a system a computational system
that tackles the linguistic phenomenon
and then we evaluate against what the
expert in the field the the humans said
to be the correct answer
cool
so
there's a lot of variability in terms of
how well we understand language and
we've seen that we we've only tackled a
small portion of the language of the
languages that exist in the world the
question is how to scale how can we take
the knowledge we currently have and just
expand it to the remaining 98 of the
world's languages and the intuition that
we
got came from looking at the big picture
and the big picture told us that
languages have a common underlying
structure
this is something that linguists after
maybe a couple of years of debate have
agreed upon and we know that languages
are structured into families and we call
those language families so for example
we have germanic languages like english
german dutch
we have roman languages like italian
french romanian we have altec languages
those are languages like turkic
languages mongolian languages koryanic
languages and we also have languages
like dravidian languages mostly spoken
in south asia
and some of the dravidian languages are
tamil telegu
and
what we've noticed is that within the
language families and across the
language families there was a
variability in terms of how well we
understood uh
each language
so our goal was to take a specific
target language for which we didn't know
how to simulate it computationally and
then just borrow knowledge from
languages from the same language family
or from more distant language families
on which we have that computational
knowledge on
and in that way we can kind of put
together a computational system that's
gonna provide us a good enough solution
for the target language on which
previously we did not have this
knowledge on and as you can see over
here uh the puzzle that we've put
together for the target language
doesn't look that perfect the pieces
don't fit together perfectly and it's
not because my photoshop skills are bad
it's because you're not going to have a
perfect solution the solution you're
going to come up with is going to be
good enough but not ideal you will be
able though to polish it further and
customize to the target language but you
will have at least a starting point
cool and the languages from which we
borrow this
linguistic knowledge we call them source
languages the language on which we apply
the knowledge are called target
languages and what we're going to see
and what i'm i'm going to discuss on
further is how to develop language
models for resource poor languages using
linguistic knowledge from resource rich
languages
and i'm going to focus on two particular
language models the one that tackles
syntactic relations and the one that
tackles semantics
okay now before i move on and i talk
about syntactic relations do you guys
have any questions
okay
now syntactic relations
to give you an example of what syntactic
relations are and how we try to model
them if we just look at the sentence
that's up there on the slide
and let's focus on the latter part of
the sentence we are yet to successfully
simulate it
when you read the sentence your brain
kind of identifies that there is a
specific action that's being referred to
in the sentence and this action is
conveyed through the verb are
and as you read the sentence you start
building uh relations between the words
in the sentence so for example you
identify the fact that we is the subject
of the sentence and the subject depends
on the verb are that yet is the adverb
and again it depends on the verb are and
so on and so forth you kind of build
structural dependencies between the
words in the sentence and what we want
to do is to simulate this kind of a
process through a computational model
and this computational model we want to
build
is called the parser this parser takes
as input a sentence
and it outputs the dependency parse for
the specific sentence
the problem we are having in the parsing
world is that we do not have parsing
systems for resource poor languages
and the approach we have taken is to
develop such multilingual purchasing
systems
that begin by identifying source
languages that are similar to specific
target language i want to focus on
and then
they selectively we selectively apply
knowledge from the source languages to
the target language
the general approach we're taking is we
start with a set of source languages the
languages that we call resource reach
because we have linguistic knowledge on
and we figure out a way to transfer
linguistic knowledge that's applicable
to our target language and use this
linguistic knowledge from the source
languages in order to train a parsing
system that is then used to
generate dependency annotations for the
target language
and the challenge at this point was how
can we select this knowledge from the
source languages right what would be a
good approach
and the first intuition we came with is
maybe if we just focus on the languages
that are from the same language family
right we already know according to
linguists that languages from the same
language family have an underlying
common structure they have a set of
shared properties so maybe if we just
bring knowledge from those sources
languages that are from the same
language family with the target language
we're going to bring the correct
knowledge and we're going to have a good
enough parsing system for our target
language
and this worked great for some of the
languages specifically for languages for
which resources were available within
this language family but if you look at
afrikaan languages if you look at
dravidian languages we just do not have
knowledge
their language family and we had to
figure out a way to bring the
appropriate knowledge without making
this assumption that we have to bring it
via the path of the language family
so the next scenario we looked at for um
bringing this knowledge on for the
target language was by assigning a set
of weights to each of the source
language
and this specific weight would tell us
how
similar the target language was compared
to our how similar the source language
was compared to our target language
specifically what that means is how
much typological similarities between
those languages and the intuition is
that if the languages are typologically
similar then i should be able to bring
the correct kind of linguistic knowledge
and train a good enough parser for my
target language
and of course these weights are between
zero and one and the higher the weight
the
the more linguistic knowledge we were
able to make from the specific source
language
the system performed better than the
language family uh
voting system where we were bringing
knowledge via the language family path
in terms that
we had less variability across the
languages on which we were evaluating on
but we've noticed something interesting
we've noticed that for example
in english i might have a sentence
that has a structure that resembles most
uh the structure of sentences in german
and i might have another sentence in
english that resembles the structure of
sentences in french so even within a
language there was variability in terms
of how the structure of sentences looked
like
and that made us think that maybe by
assigning weights at the
language level is not the the best
granular level we should focus on
and maybe we should try to weight how
relevant the source languages are
towards the target language
at the sentence level so what we we did
actually
is we took each sentence within
the target language and we assigned a
weight
for each of the source language that
would tell
relevant the
source language was compared to the
specific target sentence we were looking
at
and then we were assigning weights for
each sentence and running experiment we
were taking a new sentence assigning
ways running the experiment
this specific
experimental setting
got best results and those results were
good across all of the languages across
all of the language families they
performed better than the language level
voting system and we've also managed to
outperform um the status one of state of
the art system the state-of-the-art
system at the moment this thesis was
being read
now
bragging about how well we did i think
you guys want to see some data
and in the interest of time i'm going to
focus on the experimental results we've
obtained for the sentence-level voting
system only
uh the system where we basically
assigned weight
for the source language um and those
ways were telling what was the syntactic
similarity between the source language
and each sentence within the target
language
we evaluated our system across 16
languages from nine families
those languages were
annotated and prepared during the 2006
and 2007 kernel challenge and
in this graph that just popped up on
in this in this graphic see
the
sentence levels
system results displayed with the red
color and the language level results
displayed with the green color and you
can see that by assigning weights at the
sentence level we've managed to perform
across all of the language languages uh
the system that was assigning weight to
the language level
and specifically if you focus on some of
the languages like bulgarian slovene
arabic hungarian japanese languages that
had a very intricate
center structure we were able to obtain
quite a significant improvement compared
to when we were assigning the weight at
the language level and that is because
we were able to account for for this
variability within the center structure
of the target language
now looking at how it performed compared
to the state of the art we've evaluated
our system by looking at the
parsing system of nasimato
the system was published in 2010 if i'm
not mistaken and was having a similar
approach to parsing languages
carrying knowledge from a set of source
languages just that they were not
looking at this sentence level
granularity and
compared to the state of the art we've
managed to outperform it on 10 out of 14
languages
for
four of those languages for basque
chinese japanese and turkish we were not
able to obtain as good results but for
the remaining 10 languages we've managed
to outperform and perform better than
the language level voting system
and what we've concluded is that
sentence level parsers are the way to go
because they were able to outperform the
language level parsers and overall they
outperform the state-of-the-art system
do you guys have any questions up to
this point
so syntactic the question is how did we
judge syntactic similarity
syntactic similarity was used when we
were comparing how similar a specific
sentence was to a target language and
that was computed by looking at the
levenshtein distance between the part of
speech sequences of the
target sentence compared to all of the
sentences within the source language
uh so the question is how did we account
for pragmatics uh we do not it's very
hard to account for pragmatics mainly
because you have to have this contextual
information and there was no way for us
to to have that so for the purpose of
this research pragmatics was not
considered
yes
i'm taking outside
um
so we tried to be as
unrestrictive as possible when modeling
the the system the system was selecting
automatically from where to bring the
knowledge on so we didn't want did not
want to interfere with we know this very
variability is in the specific area just
focus on this area and bring the
knowledge from the specific language
so we do not
input any linguistic constraints or any
external knowledge
it was all learned kind of agnostic of
what was going on in terms of
variability
okay yeah
would you mind repeating that question
oh so yeah the question is how we would
represent the input versus the output
and what was that we were trying to
evaluate on the input was a sentence
like
sentence level parsers outperform
language level parsers that was a
sentence that we were taking as input
and what we wanted to take as output was
a one-on-one director dependencies for
each of the word in the within the
sentence so we wanted to know for word
number one who it depends to
and depending too means that there was
some sort of a grammatical relationship
between those words
those are the
categories of the words uh what we were
looking at was what was the relationship
between uh the parts of speech within
the sentence so the part of speech would
be this is the noun
the syntactic dependency would be this
is the subject of the sentence and it
depends on the verb
okay
now i'm going to move on and talk about
something that was a little bit harder
for us to achieve in terms of good
performance and that was semantics
and semantics is really hard to tackle
and solve computationally because it's
so ambiguous and there's there's so many
ways in which you can express things and
uh even
us uh humans the expert in the field
have a hard time
figuring out what's the right
interpretation of a specific
sentence
and one way that you can account for the
fact that the system is able to
understand the semantics of a document
or of a text is by looking at
does your system understand what are the
concepts that are being conveyed within
this document and is your system able to
build relationships within those
concepts so looking at an example uh the
one that just popped up on uh
the deck audi is an automaker that makes
luxury cars and suvs the company is
based in germany
one way you can evaluate with your
system knows what you're talking about
is by looking at does your system
recognize the fact that you're talking
about audi which is a a company that
makes luxury cars and whether it can
also identify the fact there's another
concept being mentioned and specifically
germany
and uh the way we do this is by running
a computational system through the
document we're interested in and in the
first step we would identify the
concepts that exist over there
in this case we would like to the fact
that all the
uh that the text is referring to and you
would also identify the fact that
germany is being mentioned and the
second thing you would do is you
identify the fact that there's a
relationship present and that
relationship is an identity relationship
the specific linguistic phenomenon it's
called correference resolution and what
we wanted to tackle in terms of
semantics was this problem of
co-reference resolution
of course when you do co-reference
resolution you uh look at mentions of
concept
and audi and the company are considered
the same concept and the individual
phrases audi and the company are
mentioned of a concept
and when you run a computational system
you can run it
in a sequential uh manner but you can
also run it in a end-to-end manner where
you just run through your text your that
you're interested in and you identify
the presence of mentions and the
presence of a relationship between
dimensions within the first step
and the problem we wanted to tackle in
terms of co-reference resolution was
that there were there was no
multilingual system that could perform
end-to-end co-reference resolution for
resource pro languages
and the solution we came up with was
actually designing such a system
designing a system that was able to
learn dimensions and the presence of a
reference relation between those
mentions by using the syntactic
knowledge that was brought from source
languages
by using very limited linguistic
knowledge on the target language and
that helped us design a
language-independent system
and this linguistic knowledge that we
induced into the system was um
in the form of linguistic constraints
that were universal across languages and
what that means is that we could take
our system uh consider it an
out-of-the-box system and apply it to
whatever resource poor language we have
and still understand to a certain degree
what was the semantic what were the
correference
relations for that specific language
to implement this we took a
probabilistic graphical uh model
approach uh basically we worked with a
factorial hidden markov model
that contained two layers and two
observation states the first layer in
our hidden markov model was trying to
target dimensions within the text
and basically how this factorial markov
model works is it takes a sentence and
for each word within the sentence it
considers it to be a markovian step and
at each word it tries to predict with
the first layer whether that that is the
beginning of a mention the inside of a
mention or if it's not the mention at
all so for example if i have new york
city my uh
hidden markov model is going to run
through new and then through york and
then through city and when it's at new
it's going to predict this is the big
beginning of a mansion when it's at york
is going to predict this is the inside
of a mansion and when it's a city is
going to predict says the inside again
and everything else outside of a mansion
is considered to be none
and once the system identifies that at
the specific word step there is a
mention
it also tries to predict whether there
is a co-reference relation that ties
that specific mention to other
dimensions it has seen in the past
and in order to know what it has seen in
the past it has to maintain a visibility
over
what the past looked like and the
regular implementation of a hidden
markov model only gives you visibility
over the previous time step and you can
predict what's going to happen at one
step in the future
in order to accommodate for a larger uh
history stack
we've uh enhanced this model with the
mention q
and what we were storing in this queue
were the most recent k mentions and
every time we had a new word we had to
predict the co-reference relation for we
would run through this queue of mentions
we will compute a similarity score
between the two and then we would
predict whether there is a reference
relation or not and we would predict to
which mentioned within the skew the
correference relation refers to
in terms of the observations we chose to
work with two observation states the
first one was the universal part of
speech and this is actually the word
category
that was assigned for the specific word
we were working with
and the second observation state was the
universal dependency label so basically
the dependency
relations that were generated by our
previous language model
the reason why we decided to work with
two observation states and
we've excluded modeling around words is
because we wanted the system to be
unlexicalized
that means that the system had to be
language agnostic we would be able to
apply it to whichever resource poor
language we had to tackle down
and
language agnostic is good but you still
have to put in some linguistic knowledge
and this linguistic knowledge we
implemented in the forms of linguistic
constraints
those constraints were mostly focused at
what was the dependency between the two
hidden layers of the markovian model and
one of
one such constraint basically was
telling us that if
i'm
working with new york city
and i'm in the middle at the word
york
and my model has predicted that there
exists a correference resolution at the
specific word then correference
resolution should have been predicted
for the word new as well because
correference relations have to be
carried throughout the entire mansion
another such uh constraint was that
correference cannot exist without
dimension and you can imagine why it
cannot exist and there was a handful
there were a handful of other
constraints linguistic constraints that
we modeled into this system
now looking at the experimental setup
what we did is we took the model and we
trained it over a set of source
languages and then we evaluated on the
target language to see how well we were
able to translate this linguistic
knowledge from the source languages to
the target language
and basically it was kind of a hybrid
scenario because we didn't have
linguistic knowledge available in the
target language and we were bringing
knowledge from the source languages
and to evaluate the system we looked at
and to put things into perspective
basically we had to look at how the
state-of-the-art systems were performing
we compared our system against the two
best state-of-the-art systems
the sucre and the obio systems
they were both supervised that means
that they were using linguistic
knowledge that was available for the
target language
and they were lexicalized that means
that they were modeling
around the words of the specific target
language and in comparison to those our
system was supervised but was supervised
on the source languages and it was not
lexicalized it was using the part of
speech and dependency information in
order to predict uh semantic
knowledge
now the results are
are going to be presented separately for
dimension recognition and for the core
reference resolution
tasks because those are evaluated using
different metrics for mention
recognition we
we've looked at four languages uh
catalan spanish english and dutch
compared to the 16 other languages we
were working for syntactic relations uh
correspondence resolution had a much
smaller number of languages because
annotations have not been developed for
a lot of languages it's just time
consuming and
we did not
have the time the human resources to
develop annotations
looking at the results the system we
have developed is presented in blue and
the state-of-the-art systems are
presented in a red shade
what we've noticed is that for the
romance languages for catalan and
spanish our system managed to perform
better than the second state of their
system but they didn't manage to perform
the top best system and you have to keep
in mind that this system these systems
were both trained on the target language
now for english of course uh a language
where
most the most of the linguistic
resources reside we were not able to
compete with those systems that were
trained on the target language and that
also had linguistic knowledge available
but if we look at dutch
a language where we kind of were
evaluated on the same par with the state
of their systems because linguistic
resources are not as rich for dutch
we managed to outperform both the
top state-of-the-art system and the
second best state-of-the-art systems so
given a resource per language our system
managed to outperform the
state-of-the-art systems
looking at correspondence resolution a
similar
conclusion
applied we were able to outperform the
second best this time on catalan and
english
and then we were able to perform
equally to the
top state-of-the-art system and you can
see that the state-of-the-art system has
a little advantage over us but that was
not a statistically significant
advantage so
even for co-reference resolution we were
able to outperform on languages that
were actually resource poor
now the conclusion of the of this
research is threefold and there are
three takeaway messages i would like you
guys to live with
the first one is regarding joint
learning of linguistic components right
modeling named entity recognition and
co-reference resolution together and
what we've learned it is that this joint
learning of linguistic components
benefits computational models in
resource poor and multilingual settings
the second takeaway message is regarding
cross language knowledge transfer
basically looking at granular syntactic
information that you assimilate from
source languages you can take this
knowledge and apply it to
resource poor languages and actually
build
good systems systems that manage to
tackle the puzzle for resourceful
languages
and the third conclusion is more
visionary and that is that you have to
embrace the variation you cannot expect
that you're going to have linguistic
resources or insights but you can
kind of learn how to model this unknown
and still scale language understanding
to the remaining 98 of the languages
and this is what we've tried to do this
is just the beginning we've learned that
we can walk the walk and that we can get
there in terms of generating good enough
systems for languages for which before
we didn't know how to crack the code and
there's still a lot of research to go
into it but we have some sort of
assurance that we're walking on the
right direction
and last but not least i would like to
acknowledge my wonderful advisors and
committee members
this research was made possible
due to
three funding sources the sharp project
the chateaubriand fellowship and i2b2
and also i'd like to thank my amazing
collaborators if you have any questions
i'd be more than happy to take them now
yes in the back
basically how
long it took for a system to get trained
so it depends for syntactic parsing it
was
easier because the problem was not as
complex for
um
for
understanding correference resolution
this was a little harder problem but in
general our system depends on how many
linguistic constraints we're imposing on
it
and how much data i had to chunk through
in terms of training data
but the system was able to finish within
a couple of minutes
so it was scalable in terms of time
complexity as well not just scalable in
terms of going to other languages
yep
what do you mean by graphs
uh-huh
uh so i'm not sure whether that would be
applicable in this case the documents we
were working with were newswire
documents and there was not necessarily
a speaker it was mostly a writing style
and then there was a lot of variation
across languages the documents we were
working with were not parallel documents
right um and you could not account for
the fact that this language performs
better because there's variation in
terms how the person um expresses
himself or herself rather than it's a
totally different writing style or
totally different a source from where
the knowledge is taken
or maybe it didn't get your question
so these are not translations
what we were what we were actually doing
is just
trying to consider all languages to be
a bag of knowledge and try to extract
from this bag of knowledge the knowledge
that was representative for the target
language we were looking at
so you could build translation models
but this is not what we build you could
expand this work and actually build
translation models but we were not there
in terms of with the approach we've
taken
um
yep so the first question was whether i
have a
demo around this work and uh
visualization for what i've discussed
about um i have visualization they're
not really they're not within this
presentation
uh the demo is not available we did not
build that it was
a four year long research project and
that's a bit shorter than the five year
spend that you have for a phd so i did
not have as much time and resources to
put into
presenting this as well as it should
have been uh regarding the second
question uh data is available uh some of
the data we've used is actually the
kernel data we've also developed our own
corpus which is available on my uh mit
web page so i can point you to it
afterwards if you want to take a look at
the data and the code
is in the works we're trying to make it
available for the public
yeah
parts of it
are in my thesis so i could share that
this is work if you're interested in
yeah
uh so the question is around what was
the level of
at what point you decide this is a
resource pro language and you can
actually build a model for and i think
you're hinting at uh the fact that we
had resources even for the resource pro
languages but we didn't right so
this approach should work for any
language that you maybe just come across
in
a hebrew text and you don't know how to
process it and you don't know that's
hebrew and you could just go ahead and
apply the system to it and understand
what are the syntactic relations and
understand what are the semantics for
the specific document so we make no
assumptions about what resources are
available for
the resource poor languages
that's a good question yeah
so would you mind repeating the question
what
uh-huh
so some of the challenges we had to face
were when the set of source languages
was not as relevant towards the target
language we had to work with and we saw
that challenge very visibly when we
didn't outperform the state of the art
on those four languages because those
languages were very structurally
different and they did not have any like
much similarity to what was in the set
of source languages and for those
languages it might have happened that
maybe there's nothing similar to them
right
we were not able to reach that
conclusion because we did not have an
even larger set of source languages to
work with and the languages the source
languages we were working with were kind
of connected in terms of the language
families they were coming from so it was
either four languages from the same
language family were
only one language from a specific
language family there was not much um
you don't have many siblings within the
language families
uh
so that was a problem and partially it
was addressed by the fact that we
allowed uh sentences uh to be modeled
from different set of languages
depending on is their productivity or
non-productivity
so in a sense that addressed this
problem of different structures and
different types of dependencies across
languages
um i don't think
did you get by any chance
i'm curious um
if you like the hat how
multi-word expressions
of those
were represented in the different
language families you know you alluded
to
the new york city example
and co-reference resolution i'm just
curious if you looked at how
multi-word expressions were represented
in the different families uh so
multi-word express the question is how
do multi-world expressions play in the
uh world of
reference resolution because to the core
reference resolution you have to first
identify dimensions and sometimes
dimensions span multiple words in
languages like english you have a lot of
such expressions that span multiple
words in languages like german you have
those multiple words concatenated
together and this no longer becomes a
problem
so
that was definitely a challenge
that's why
most of the times when we do evaluation
we look at
a partial evaluation schema where even
though you've missed the word of your
concept you still
grant the right credit to your system
and this is the way we kind of tackled
this challenge by
granting the right
credit even though there was one missing
word maybe the beginning or maybe the
end of it
and uh
if we had for example if we had to
predict on english and we were training
on french then we would obtain better
accuracy in english compared to when we
were training just in uh
on german and had to apply to english
because german would tell us that most
of the mentions had to be only one word
mentioned so
those are still challenges that have to
be addressed and we don't have a perfect
solution for them
very good question yeah
they're
discrete either a match
well
when
annotators annotate the documents they
might have a probabilistic mention
criteria right because some of them
might say
this mention is four words and some
other might say this mention is five
words but we give them a guideline right
then we would annotate against the
guideline and then we have um
an external person who comes in and
decides on what's the right number of
words to include and once we decide that
does the right number of worst things
include that's what we expect of our
system to predict
so
but there there is a variability with
language in general there's a lot of
ambiguity and there's a lot of ways you
could interpret what it's supposed to be
predicted and what the system is
predicting and what we found actually is
that for some of the languages our
system was predicting uh the correct
mentions such as that the annotations
were incorrect but you evaluate against
the annotations and you have to assume
that's the gold standard
so it depends what the the annotation
guideline specifies uh because those
should be things clarified in annotation
guideline and then when you train uh
your system learns that it's supposed to
include or exclude processing and we do
not we did not work with overlapping
mentions they were supposed to be
one-off yeah
does it perform
can you hear me uh yeah would you mind
repeating it because now i can hear you
how where is the model performed you
know particular internal semantics
is like able functioning not a tiniest
old child or you know it's a
i mean how well does it perform you mean
how good is the performance of the model
how well
how accurate oh yeah how accurate
semantics wise
semantics wise semantics wise uh so the
performance of the model as shown in the
previous slide varies from
um
dimension recognition tasks and uh
reference resolution task on mention
recognition were able to do better
around sixty percent seventy percent for
some of the languages co reference
resolution the best performance was
around forty percent core reference
resolution on the other hand is uh
evaluated more stringently because your
model will identify mentions but if
those mentions are not in a specific
relation there's a
there's a different way to wait how
you consider the identification of
mentions that are in relation or not but
overall going with the current metrics
that are considered gold standard we
were obtaining 40
and those are the mach b cubed and caf
metrics
uh for which part for syntactic relation
there's a lot of approaches syntactic
relation has well been uh investigated
correspondence resolution is not um i
mean there's a lot of working call
reference resolution but not a lot of
work where there was done uh joint
learning over the two different tasks
that are required so for uh
correspondence resolution this was one
of the first approaches and also the
first approach that was working with
multilingual knowledge
we can talk more offline if you'd like